hey what is up guys my name is Aero and
welcome to the second episode of my
morning coffee
Series today we're going to cover
variables there are six variables in
Java capable of storing numbers we're
going to take a look at three of them
today first up is bite the bite variable
can contain any value from -128 to POS
127 255 numbers in all it's the smallest
variable in Java and thus uses the least
memory it only stores integers short is
the second smallest variable ranging
from
32,768 to POS
32,767 short is probably the least used
variable in Java now as it was useful in
the past for 16-bit computing which has
since become very rare after short we
have int short for integer it stores
integers anywhere from -2.1 billion
roughly to positive 2.1 billion and is
by far the most popular choice of
variable for storing integers so all of
this begs the question if I can use int
why should I use bite or short two
reasons first one is usability if you
know that you don't need a variable
exceeding say 100 you might as well use
a bite as a simply won't store anything
much more than 100 second reason is
performance this isn't really a matter
of processing time although in large
arrays and I'm talking Millions I found
using bite to be around 3.2% faster than
int to process yeah not a lot however if
you're using many many arrays and don't
need the space for an INT variable use a
shorter bite your memory usage will be
significantly lower because instead of
storing a million ins it's storing a
million bytes and that's smaller by
roughly around 75% less memory
usage thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed the video I'll be back tomorrow
with the rest of the numeric variables
long float and double until then goodbye